halo infinite's first in-game event hits
200 000 players on steam war zone
secrets of the pacific event is now live
and more
halo infinite's multiplayer beta is
soaring to new heights the game reached
more than 200 thousand peak concurrent
players on steam recently and the spike
in players is surely due in part to the
launch of halo infinite's very first
multiplayer event fracture tin rye which
released on november 23rd the player
figures were posted on steam's public
player data page in exceeding 200 000
peak concurrent players halo infinite is
one of the most popular games on steam
overall the game is also available on
microsoft store on pc and through xbox
but similar player data figures were not
available for those platforms halo
infinite multiplayer is free which makes
comparing its success to earlier titles
a little more challenging but whatever
the case halo infinite is clearly off to
a strong start despite issues and
concerns people have with the xp and
progression systems on that front 343
community director brian gerrard
recently said the studio hears the
feedback loud and clear updates might
not be released immediately however as
the team is taking a break for the
holidays 343 already made some changes
to the xp and progression systems but
more robust updates are coming later on
the fracture tinrite event adds new
cosmetics a new fiesta mode which spawns
you with a random weapon every life and
more the event won't be around for too
long though you have until november 30th
to get those levels
call of duty vanguard will get warzone
integration with the new caldera map on
december 8th but raven software has a
few limited time events for players to
bid farewell to burdansk following the
ongoing operation flashback event
secrets of the pacific is now live in a
call of duty blog secrets of the pacific
is described as an event that will grant
players vital information on caldera and
its various points of interest prior to
the december launch little other details
are known about this upcoming event but
the secrets are apparently uncovered by
completing challenges across both
vanguard and warzone each game will have
its own set of tasks and rewards for
completing them one of which activision
describes as acquiring and protecting
pacific artifacts while fighting to
survive in verdansk it's possible
secrets of the pacific will work
similarly to past events like the
haunting and the numbers event which
offered weapons and cosmetic items for
completing set objectives however no
rewards have been mentioned by
activision just yet one final event is
scheduled for players to save farewell
to warzone's original location though
from november 30th until the preseason's
end war zone will feature the last hours
of verdansk which is vaguely described
as watching to see what happens to
berdansk before war zone goes dark to
prepare for caldera
activision also says to expect a
spectacular and fitting into your time
in verdansk as we say farewell to
castobian city forever
the new caldera map is set to launch on
december 8th for vanguard owners and on
the 9th for everyone else
battlefield 2042 has already attracted
millions of players after its full
release on november 19th but the
multiplayer only battlefield title has
fans expressing disappointment with a
buggy launch and lack of legacy features
but today dice has restated its
commitment to the game promising in a
blog post that it will be supporting and
evolving it for years to come the post
gives a road map on planned updates and
changes coming to battlefield 2042
starting with update number two which is
due to release on thursday november 25th
this update will be followed by an even
larger update number three in early
december with dice saying that a further
update after this will hopefully be out
before the holidays as well further down
the track the studio will start
revealing details about the game's first
season in 2022 the developer also
restated its commitment to including
various legacy features that aren't
present in the current version of the
game though it doesn't currently have a
timeline for these features into the
match scoreboard server browser and
features like voice chat are big topics
for us to cover all at once and we have
plenty we want to say around them the
post reads we'll come back to you when
we have things that we can show you
including details about our long term
vision for certain features and
functions update number two will also
include some changes to the hovercraft a
vehicle that early players found had the
ability to travel vertically of
buildings since the game went live we
saw the hovercraft become a fan favorite
given its high durability and
effectiveness in combat the post reads
we designed this vehicle to behave as an
alternative to the latview 4 but not as
an upgrade in thursday's update number 2
we have balanced the health of this
vehicle to bring it more in line with
its design and made sure that its
weaponry is appropriately effective even
more details for update number two are
said to be on the way and there have
been some details on update number three
mentioned already if you want the full
rundown of every note we have so far be
sure to check out our full write-up on
gamespot.com
kojima has posted a cryptic teaser for
what looks like a new project and people
believe norman reedus may be involved
again kojima posted the teaser photo
with the caption recently i've been
revising the plan and script and
experimenting with everything else and
someone in the foreground looks like it
could possibly be norman reedus but
nothing is confirmed of course what are
you hoping will be kojima's next big
reveal let me know in the comments and
hopefully your prediction comes true and
we'll see something at the game awards
leave a like subscribe and make sure you
all have a wonderful holiday we'll see
you next time
you